now you can see we said all right we got
from the stage of being a problem like
what the what do we do with this until
such a point as we reduce it into a
problem that we're very comfortable with
more or less anyway like you've got some
algebraic crunching here to do so you're
going to expand this get another non
monic messy quadratic eventually you're
going to have a quadratic equals to zero
what did you get
it's got like it must be 5x squared
something right plus sign 121 okay now
when you get to this point when you get
to this point it does look messy but in
fact some of the numbers will help you
realize actually there's a very nice
lead factorization in this right it
looks like it's going to be 5x minus 11
sorry 5x minus ru what's 5x minus 11 yep
and X minus 11 yeah that's what gives
you that I'm 100 21 that's equal to zero
so as usual you look at that you say I
know what to do with this if either one
of these is zero then I get the whole
thing being zero so therefore I have a
an ear to hear that's sort of fifth and
I also have an answer here okay now I
said before hey watch out because as we
progress from y1 to line five we've
changed the problem we made it workable
but we also adjusted it and we've
potentially added more solutions in now
one of the ways that you can check
whether you've gone from something which
doesn't solutions is something that does
is to look for domain restrictions I've
warned you about this before but I
deliberately didn't say it to see if you
would twig like oh that's a danger okay
so have a look see these three functions
that make up the original problem each
one has a domain restriction let's start
with this one the square root of x
normally has the domain restriction of
what X is greater than or equal to zero
now the square root of x plus five is
not the same as the square of X it's
moved around which way is it going it's
going to the left five units so it's no
longer X is greater than
zero its X is greater than ya five units
to the left so that's the restriction
you get from this guy okay
these all have restrictions that are
similar this one will be X is greater
than or equal to just positive two and
this one is X is greater than or equal
to six on file so when you have a look
at these right which one starts furthest
to the left this guy starts furthest to
the left right and then in order it
looks like this one would come next and
then this one comes last
but all three need to exist together in
order for this to have any meaning so
therefore the one that really matters is
this guy yeah now when you look at that
for the first thing it looks sort of
okay because that's 2.2 and that's 11 so
on domain restriction grounds everything
looks clear however you remember I
mentioned we squared not once but twice
so I'm still suspicious domain
restrictions are not the only things
that can cause problems so therefore
this is a bit awkward but there's no
real way to get around it and it's kind
of okay because there are only two
solutions you have to test I'd likely
expect you to know what these graphs
look like well actually you can probably
get that but that's just some kind of
garbled mess so how am I going to test
this quickly the most efficient way is
just to substitute in okay let's try
eleven because that's a whole numbers
that's fairly easy what's going to
happen over here on the left-hand side
you're going to get the square root of
16 plus the square root of 9 so four
plus three is seven that's what I'm
hoping for
let's try it under my head side the
square root of 55 minus six is the
square root of 49 that checks out
doesn't it so this guy looks good okay
now eleven over five I do not expect you
to try and work this out in your head so
you reach for your calculator and when
you test this what does the left-hand
side equal three you're going to get
some decimal rubbish that's fine okay
what does the right height are equal
okay so just simply by it's a bit
quicker daily but it works right we've
discovered this guy is actually a bit of
a dud okay and where's it come from
it came from this process here every
time you square you add in the chance
for more solutions to exist okay
I in fact a little bit of homework for
you cool excuse me go ahead right into
Dez boss pop this in see what the graph
looks like okay and pop this in so the
graph looks like and you will find the
one and one only solution right here but
then if you compare that to this slide
here is when we finished squaring okay
this slide here do you see why it's not
that surprising you would expect two
solutions out of this because what's the
right hand side what shape is it it's a
parabola what shape is this it's another
parabola
well not that surprising if I just make
up some random problems here's one and
here's another one well it's not that
surprising that you would find two
solutions you've made the shapes more
complicated okay